diving deep into murky water the salvage
team undertook a complicated mission
they hauled a large fragment of
meteorite 20 meters to the surface of
the lake it's beautiful it's gorgeous
and approximately this size the chunk
was no lightweight when the team he's
did onto the scales at clocked in at 570
kilograms men it broke the piece of
apparatus the boulder crumbled into
pieces as well researchers said they
would soon put the rock under the
microscope to verify that it was in fact
a meteorite at the filter we need to
conduct a full examination including a
structural analysis and other tests we
do for this kind of material it was back
on februari 15th that the meteor blazedd
across the russian region Chelyabinsk
its path was captured by countless
amateur video cameras over 1,600 people
were injured by the shock wave from the
explosion it was the largest media crash
in 66 years researchers think there are
more fragments lying at the bottom of
the lake for now they will remain there
while the team celebrate their
spectacular find which will soon become
a museum piece